[Music]
Nefertiti are two of the most important
and Fascinating People from ancient
Egypt in Egypt's golden couple we pull
back the curtain to show you how we know
what we know about akhnatan and
Nefertiti
is presented by some as a complete Saint
or as a horrible monster Nefertiti is
frequently said to have been the most
beautiful woman of her time and yet on
on what information are any of these
statements base what can we actually
know about people who lived 3000 years
ago we don't know enough to produce
let's say a biography like you might
write about a modern personality at the
same time we can reconstruct an average
day in the life of an Egyptian of the
period we try to write a biography where
akhn and never
do or what they believed because there's
so much they've left behind and instead
while agnat and Nefertiti are truly
revolutionary they've become Gods on
Earth what they do is rooted in
thousands of years of Egyptian tradition
and Nefertiti themselves are in fact the
children of the solar deity they're the
first male female pair coming from the
Creator God
for the ancient Egyptians the skin of
the Gods was gold since Oxnard and
Nefertiti are the Son and Daughter of
auten they truly are Egypt's golden
couple
[Music]